you mentioned jared goff i don't know
that anyone in their right mind is going
to trade for the jared goff contract as
it's currently structured 43 million is
fully guaranteed to him with limited
offsets for the next two years and
reportedly and not shockingly the rams
are going to have an open competition at
quarterback i mean everything that sean
mcveigh the coach of the team unless
sneed the gm of the team have said since
the rams were eliminated two weekends
ago
suggest that they are done with jared
goff and they would wash their hands of
him if they could but they can't so you
bring in others to compete with goff and
you may have the highest paid backup
quarterback in the history of sports if
he ends up losing the job to john
walford or duck hodges or blake bortles
or someone else
look i think the biggest thing with the
rams right now is
they have to figure out if there's any
way they can make golf palatable
to another team
i think that is their that's their
biggest job this off season
i i just don't think it's smart after
you have hung them out to dry very early
in the off season to have them come to
training camp and say never mind
it's not realistic
i have no idea why
uh especially les sneed this week said
what he said
i mean to me it cuts out all your
leverage
and it it just it may it made no sense
to me
so you know to me i i i think that
they've dug themselves a whole
and the smartest thing for them although
you're right mike it may be impossible
the smartest thing for them
is to try to get rid of this contract uh
somehow some way maybe by eating a bunch
of it but if i were them that's what i'd
do
they dug the hole two years ago when
they signed the contract now the dirt is
falling back into the hole and they're
trying to scramble out of it that's the
problem and peter sims and i were trying
to get to the bottom of this and why
this is happening you know my idea was
maybe goff just
just got lazy and complacent he's not
working very hard and they're just done
with him they're exasperated with him
and that's why they're calling him out
and not defending him and sims
perspective on it is and he could be
more accurate than i am that you get to
a point where you potentially lose the
locker room when you constantly defend
the guy who's clearly the weak link of
your team like the jaguars did for all
those years with blake bortles you get
to a point where you have no credibility
in the locker room because everybody
else knows this guy's the problem why
does coach continue to kiss his butt and
act like he's a great quarterback when
he isn't and maybe it's a combination of
factors but we've never seen this from
sean mcvay we've never seen this from
les snead and at least they're kind of
acknowledging the mistake they made but
the problem is they have no path out of
it there's no easy path and like you
said they may have to eat some of that
43 million like the dolphins did to
clear ryan tannehill off the roster it's
ridiculous to think that they actually
had to pay part of his salary two years
ago to unload him onto the titans but
that may be what the rams have have to
do
you know the other the other issue here
mike i i think is that
and i
really agree with chris and i think
that's probably one of the issues and
look i i i do not mean to jump on the
chicago bears okay but i do think
that
part of you know when matt nagy whenever
looks back at this period in his life
just my feeling my feeling is that he's
gonna wish
that
he was stronger with ryan pace and with
team management and said at the end of
2019
you know
this we need to be merciful in all ways
i mean it's obvious that the team
doesn't believe in trubisky
and you know it's obvious that uh that
he's he's shaky so let's go full bore
instead of scotch tape in this thing
with nick foles let's go full bore and
go get another quarterback and start
working with him right now and to me
that is what i sense what the rams want
to do
rather than bring back jared goff
and watch him play the way he's played
for the last two years which is
mostly
kind of shaky okay
rather than watch that let's make a
clean break
and let's start over and let's train a
young quarterback to be
just what washington did with kirk
cousins
you know just what the packers did quite
honestly with aaron rodgers i mean
cousins didn't end up playing as much
for washington obviously but
train a guy get them ready and have them
do what you want the quarterback to do
and i agree with that and look one of
the biggest mistakes that nfl teams can
make or really in any area of business
is to not admit your mistakes and double
down and triple down and quadruple down
so at least the rams acknowledge that
that this thing needs to end it's just
not going to be the easiest thing to end
it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports